la femme on vous lit la fois bon jour
alors comment expliquer ce taux de
mortalité aussi élevé dans le
département alors il faut savoir que
plusieurs départements français qui ont
été fortement touchées par la pandémie
ont enregistré une mentalité en hausse
mais il est vrai qu'en seine saint denis
les chiffres sont impressionnants
vous l'avez dit entre le 21 et le 27
mars le département enregistré une
hausse de 63 % des décès par rapport à
la semaine précédente
pour comparaison la hausse atteint 32% à
paris et 47 % dans le département voisin
du val d'oise alors la direction de la
santé dit ne pas avoir d'explication
dans l'immédiat compte à ces chiffres
plusieurs facteurs pourraient expliquer
cette surmortalité tout d'abord certains
élus locaux pointe du doigt un système
de santé plus faibles qui pèsent sur
l'accès aux soins
il faut savoir qu'en seine saint denis
il y a moins de médecins et de lits de
réanimation que dans d'autres
territoires français et puis dans ce
département qui compte 1,5 million
d'habitants l'un des plus denses de
france le virus circule beaucoup plus
facilement qu'ailleurs et puis plus
qu'ailleurs on a affaire à une
population précaire et le confinement
est complexe dans ces territoires
défavorisés où il y a beaucoup de
familles nombreuses
dans des petits logements parfois des
logements insalubres et puis enfin une
autre piste d'explication qui est
peut-être du point de vue socio
professionnelles cette fois ci dans ces
territoires il ya beaucoup d' aides
soignantes des aides à domiciles des
caissières encore des livreurs qui
doivent continuer à aller travailler et
qui se retrouve de fait très exposé
merci beaucoup
li la fin vaut pour toutes les
précisions en direct de votre lieu de
confinement